[Music]
on this Monday night the deaths of a
respected politician Winnipeg MP Jim
Carr honored by political friends and
foes it was like my parliamentary dad I
used to say to him every day how are you
feeling Jiminy said every day counts the
looming and critical task this is on the
high end of complexity a forensic
anthropologist on searching a landfill
for murdered indigenous women
nature and modern medicine the
consequences of climate change on
prescription drugs plus the pursuit of
clean power the industry's been chasing
this for a long time the science behind
a breakthrough
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us the
business of parliament came to an abrupt
halt today because of some sad news A
Member of Parliament from Winnipeg Jim
Carr has died we often report on
politicians criticizing each other well
today is different Carr who was a proud
liberal and a former cabinet minister is
being remembered fondly by politicians
of every stripe it will stand for a
moment of silence for the passing of The
Honorable member
Jim Carr
just last week while seriously ill with
blood cancer Carr was in the House of
Commons overseeing the passage of his
private members bill on building a green
economy on the prairies
was
incredibly thoughtful and Incredibly
passionate about this country about his
region about the community
dedicated to service dedicated to a
better future for all Canadians
it is the example he set his unfailing
commitment as a public servant and his
efforts to build Bridges rather than
pick fights that Carr is being
remembered for today Mackenzie gray has
our top story tonight Mr Carr it was his
last act in Parliament I declared the
motion carried
liberal MP Jim Carr lauded for having a
private members Bill he sponsored past
just five days before he died a rare
moment for any politician which
underscored the respect MPS had for Carr
I had the honor of sitting beside Jim he
was a wonderful human being and um
I used to say them every day how are you
feeling Jim and he said every day counts
the great loss for Canada for Manitoba
for the Prairie West
for Jim's Family he's a mentor and uh
I said to my team he's like my
parliamentary dad
despite our parts and differences I've
always considered a friend he's a great
champion from Manitoba she's uh smart
qualified first elected in 2015 Carr was
one of only a handful of liberals from
western Canada leading Justin Trudeau to
appoint him as natural resources
Minister where he helped craft the
federal government's carbon tax in 2018
as International Trade Minister Carl
oversaw Canada becoming one of the first
countries to ratify the trans-pacific
partnership but just one day after being
elected to represent Winnipeg South
Center in 2019 Carr was diagnosed with
blood cancer I just know that I'm loyal
to my treatment and I'm feeling strong
and I'm feeling very excited about the
prospects for Canada despite the
positive attitude Carr took a step back
from politics prime minister naming him
is a special representative for the
Prairies but he was rarely seen in
Ottawa staying in Winnipeg to receive
chemotherapy and dialysis treatment one
year after his diagnosis Carr returned
virtually to the House of Commons here
we are less than a year later and I'm
feeling strong I'm grateful and I'm
ready to work
along with so many others with their own
experience by 2021 cars condition had
improved he'd been dropped from cabinet
but he was still a champion for Winnipeg
like he was before he got into Federal
politics Carr was previously in MLA in
Manitoba and a journalist but it was his
musical Pursuits that many colleagues
will remember him for he was a hobo
player had had played in the Winnipeg
symphonic orchestra
she was also
not only a patient for the Arts but a
strong supporter of the business
Community not support for Manitoba will
not only be sorely missed in the liberal
caucus but the loss of Jim Carr will be
felt on all sides of the House of
Commons
Mackenzie gray Global News
Ottawa
now to the pressure on Winnipeg Police
to search a private landfill site for
the remains of two murdered indigenous
women last week Winnipeg's police chief
explained why the force didn't think a
search of the site is feasible today we
asked forensic anthropologists who are
experts in recovering human remains what
they think as Melissa ridgeen explains
searches of landfills are complex and
success depends on many factors
the planning Logistics part is really
important to get right because once you
you know process these um these scenes
you can't do it a second time it's a
massive undertaking digging up a
landfill and not making any mistakes but
in the case of a suspected serial killer
suspected of murdering at least four
indigenous women the task is even more
onerous made worse by conditions at the
privately owned Prairie green landfill
where at least two of the victims are
believed to be
Winnipeg Police believe Morgan Harris
and Mercedes Myron have been in a Four
Acre part of this landfill since May
under 40 feet of densely compacted waste
nine thousand tons of construction mud
1500 tons of animal remains and 250 tons
of asbestos
Dr Stephanie calche a forensic
anthropologist who's consulted with
police in other landfill searches says
machines didn't just compact materials
but time that's completely been
destroyed right so now we have this
completely compressed context of time
um it's very large so we don't quite
know where to start there which means we
have to search all of it I think this is
on the high end of complexity but it's
not impossible homicide victim Nathaniel
bertel's family got closer when his
remains were found in a seven-month
search at an Ontario landfill they had
very good information on where to start
they had very good information on what
material they were going to be dealing
with where and how it was moved within
the site so they were able to really
focus on their search efforts she
suspects mounting public pressure has
police figuring out what outside
resources could help with a search for
Harris and Myron and an unknown victim
the elders have named Buffalo Woman
Messiah murdered indigenous women and
girls Advocates suspect there were
others no one knows about and say both
landfills should be shut down and
searched the Police Services Board has
admitted this is an undertaking that
Winnipeg Police can't do alone the
province has said they will provide
whatever assistance is needed but
whatever the search entails it's not
expected to give families closure
anytime soon and maybe months down the
road Melissa Ridge in Global News
Winnipeg
there is a national toll-free Crisis
Line available 24 7 for anyone who
requires emotional assistance related to
missing and murdered indigenous women
the number is 1-844-413-6649
well you're probably already feeling it
and now stats Canada has confirmed it
the amount Canadian households owe
relative to their income Rose in the
third quarter of 2022. the ratio of
household debt to income increase
between July and September Canadians now
owe 1.83 for every dollar of disposable
income they have increasingly High
interest payments or a big factor Rising
16.2 percent in that period the largest
increase on record
and those rapid fire interest rate hikes
are starting to work that's according to
the governor of the Bank of Canada in a
speech in Vancouver today Tiff Macklin
said the risk of not raising interest
rates enough and having inflation run
wild is greater than the risk of raising
them too much and fueling a recession
if High inflation sticks much higher
interest rates will be required to
restore price stability
and the economy will have to slow even
more
to restore price stability
bringing down inflation Macklin says
also depends on geopolitical events
reflecting on 2022 he says the bank was
surprised by persistent Supply problems
the Russian invasion of Ukraine and a
spike in demand after pandemic
restrictions eased Iran has publicly
executed a second ban who the regime
accused of killing two security
officials during protests he was hanged
from a crane at dawn this morning
Amnesty International says it's clear
the regime is using public executions to
try to instill fear in Iranians who have
been protesting the regime's Hardline
policies for months Redmond Shannon
reports the last known video of majeed
Reza ranavard alive before his execution
the 23 year old in an Iranian Court
appearing to justify his hatred of
Iran's besiege volunteer paramilitary
Force authorities convicted him of
killing two besieged members based on
this grainy CCTV footage and a recorded
statement after his arrest where he
neither confessed to nor denied the
attack his execution was just three
weeks after the incident and just four
days after mozen shikari was also hanged
for assaulting another basige member
these executions have taken place
following sham politically motivated
trial with the authorities violating the
most basic standards of fair trial there
is serious concern that he had been
subjected to torture and other
ill-treatment human rights groups say
almost 500 other protesters have been
killed in clashes with authorities
the Country-Wide demonstrations began in
September after the death of Masa amini
in custody arrested for wearing her
hijab improperly even in the close
officials to the government they
admitted that the government is in a
very dark situation it's just quite
desperate and they are trying whatever
they can to just intimidate people and
it's not working as of yet Canada added
22 more Iranians to a sanctions list
last week the EU followed on Monday we
are targeting those responsible for this
continued repression against protesters
as other protesters face execution human
rights Advocates say the International
Community should go further to Target
the assets of supreme leader Ali
Khamenei as well as those of Iran's
revolutionary guard Corps a Canadian
court has ruled it to be a terrorist
entity but the Trudeau government has
yet to fully classify it as such Redmond
Shannon Global News London
it's been nearly 34 years since Pan Am
103 on route from London to New York
City exploded over Lockerbie Scotland
just days before Christmas all 259
people on board and 11 people on the
ground were killed a bomb was hidden in
a suitcase many of the Dead were
American and now a former Libyan
intelligence officer is in U.S custody
accused of making that bomb and charged
with an act of international terrorism
Jackson prosco reports on a day the
families of the victims thought they'd
never see
facing Justice on American soil a former
Libyan intelligence operative made his
first appearance in a Washington Court
Abu agila Muhammad Masood is accused of
making the bomb hidden in a stereo that
brought down Pan Am flight 103 in 1988
killing 270 including 190 Americans and
two Canadians it was the largest
terrorist attack on U.S civilians prior
to September 11th it's the first
significant step to begin to address
these three decades-long miscarriage of
Justice Victoria camox husband John was
one of the victims returning home to his
family on flight 103 just days before
Christmas I wasn't sure if you know
within my lifetime we would be able to
see the days the lack of American
prosecution has long remained an open
wound for victims families the only
person ever convicted in the bombing
Abdel hassad al-magrahi was released
from prison on compassionate grounds
before his death from cancer in 2012.
masoods transferred to U.S custody comes
two years after the charges were first
announced while he was already in a
Libyan prison at long last this man
responsible for killing Americans and
many others will be subject to justice
for his crimes yet after more than 30
years prosecutors may have a difficult
time securing a conviction Witnesses and
corroborating evidence may be hard to
come by at the same time it's hope the
trial may open new leads in the
investigation and potentially reveal the
true story behind the bombing this is
something that
um we have fought for
um to bring Justice and and hold those
accountable for who murdered our loved
ones it's unclear how exactly the U.S
negotiated masood's extradition but
prosecutors will not seek the death
penalty the victim's families say they
want the trial to start immediately so
that Justice delayed is no longer
Justice denied Jackson prosco Global
News Washington
the Hefty price tag for catering on a
trip the governor general took coming up
the expenses of federal panel calls
unacceptable
the former CEO of a cryptocurrency
exchange that collapsed has been
arrested in the Bahamas Sam bankman
freed was arrested at the request of U.S
authorities that's according to the
attorney general in the Bahamas the
company the 30 year old founded FTX was
valued at 30 billion dollars before
becoming insolvent and filing for
bankruptcy leaving hundreds of investors
including some celebrities with huge
losses the Bahamas says the U.S has
filed criminal charges against bankman
freed and is likely to request his
extradition prosecutors in New York City
say the indictment will be unsealed
tomorrow
in Ottawa today federal employees face
questions about spending on the governor
General's trip to the Middle East in
March much of the testimony at the House
of Commons government operations and
estimates committee focused on a list of
things the committee calls unacceptable
including receipts for ice cubes that
cost 565 dollars 110 dollars for four
liters of apple juice and 556 dollars
for lemons and limes when questioned the
chief of protocol said new measures to
avoid costs like this in the future are
already in place
there will be no longer any choice of
meal for passengers in the main cabin
which will produce for us significant
reductions in overage things that would
be normally part of uh standard
international uh air travel such as ice
drink garnishes we'll be looking at all
of those costs as well
the eight day trip for 12 people cost
taxpayers over a million dollars
[Music]
pharmaceutical plants ahead why
preserving nature is critical to Medical
advancements
[Music]
the largest ever leak in the Keystone
Pipeline in the U.S has now been stopped
and the cleanup is beginning the leak
was detected Wednesday night in Northern
Kansas an emergency shutdown happened
immediately it's believed more than 2.2
million liters of crude leaked into a
nearby Creek the cause of that leak is
under investigation restarting the
pipeline will require the green light
from U.S Regulators the Keystone
Pipeline owned by Canadian TC energy
moves more than 600 thousand barrels per
day from Alberta to refineries on the
U.S Gulf Coast we've heard a lot about
the need to protect biodiversity and
there's one reason that may surprise you
much of what we rely on for medicine
comes from plants and there's still much
more we're learning as we humans
encroach on nature and species go
extinct we're losing the very things
that can help Keep Us Alive Toria isri
reports on the link between biodiversity
and Medicine
what many would consider gross this
biologist sees as a gold mine
Carleton University Professor Myron
Smith researches fungi and bacteria
and how they can be used to develop new
drugs it's a pressing need because the
world's medicine cabinet is shrinking we
have
fallen behind in the race to develop new
strategies and new compounds to inhibit
pathogens
climate change development and over
harvesting are wiping out ecosystems and
all the information they hold saving
endangered animals and plants is the
goal of caught 15 in Montreal Humanity
has become a weapon of mass extinction
it's a cost ecologist Jeremy Kerr
believes is impossible to measure
because of all the potential still
hiding how crucial are plants when it
comes to the discovery of new drugs
40 of the drugs that are on our shelves
right now may be as much as 50 of the
drugs come from plants
species for their pharmaceutical
benefits we are removing drugs from our
shelves that might give us cures to
things that are incredibly important
researchers warned they're particularly
important with the rise of antibiotic
resistant bugs
and also habitat loss which is forcing
disease-carrying animals closer to
humans and increasing the chances of
another pandemic we don't really know
what's coming at us in the future and we
probably want to hedge our bets a little
bit and make sure that we have
everything available that we might need
s the best way
greatest laugh
ER
teria isri Global News
Ottawa
fusion power next the Breakthrough that
could lead to a future of clean energy
there is New Hope of a breakthrough in a
decades-long quest to harness nuclear
fusion and produce Limitless zero carbon
energy there's lots of hype right now
about what U.S researchers are set to
announce tomorrow it's expected to be
details of how they've cracked what
until now has been impossible Eric
Sorensen explains what nuclear fusion is
and the research underway including here
in Canada that holds so much promise
it sounds too good to be true energy
that is neither polluting nor
radioactive nuclear fusion the same
energy that powers the sun and stars
fusing atoms has been an elusive Force
an unsustainable energy for scientists
to replicate on Earth too much energy
goes in for what comes out now
scientists at the Lawrence Livermore
laboratory in California have made a
breakthrough that they will announce
Tuesday similar work is underway a
general Fusion in Vancouver where
they're pioneering plasmas to create a
net energy gain Fusion is the Holy Grail
of energy the industry's been chasing
this for a long time achieving those
conditions in a way that you get more
energy out than what you put in uh isn't
is is a big important step for about 75
years the world has harnessed nuclear
power using fission energy that comes
from splitting atoms infusion atoms are
joined creating bigger atoms also
releasing energy what difference does
that make well in fission heavier atoms
are needed primarily uranium as well as
Pluto which are radioactive and you're
left with used nuclear Fuel That Remains
contaminated for tens of thousands of
years infusion lighter atoms such as
hydrogen can be smashed together and
what's produced are larger helium atoms
creating even more powerful energy with
little or no radioactive waste nuclear
fission energy is a legacy that Canada
in particular must deal with Ontario's
Bruce nuclear plant stores more than a
million spent radioactive bundles in
huge containers for which a permanent
disposal site must still be found the
race for clean fusion power is on in
Labs all over the world with its partner
in the UK General Fusion plans to build
a demonstration power plant that will be
up and running in about four years with
a full-scale commercial plant on the
grid in the early 2030s you're creating
a mini sun on the earth uh and so when
you're doing that inside a machine you
can imagine the damage that happens to
it you can imagine the challenges with
extracting that that energy and actually
converting it to something useful and
putting it on on the grid at one time
Fusion seemed an unattainable maybe even
unnecessary pipe dream but in the era of
climate change there is increasing
awareness that clean energy solutions
for future Generations have to be
developed now Fusion could be a big part
of that cleaner safer future Eric
Sorensen Global News Toronto
and that is global national for this
Monday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's your
Canada is the Canadian Museum of Nature
in Ottawa we'd love to see your festive
Canada photos please email them to
viewers at globalnational.com thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]